он і було прямого знайду пізньої ночі
італійський прем'єр материнський був
центральною фігурою піджак дебатів
саме хотів здаватися на полігоні їм
вінцеслава санкції набрали тексту
укладені резолюцій з контексту
критикою росії зайди в сирі та вкраде
кейнана поважаючий на батьківщині годину після про
десанте цілісно це політику вирубали
міністра за кордон і праворуч набився
імені прагнули теріана flurry ридж
околиці були за жорсткі шу лінію ще до
Москви засіки негайної Франції
проект фінального документу саміту
містер формулювання промисловість
розвідданих сантин адресу росії до
вчиню злочини такого готування
продовжіть ми розглянемо у все можна віза
майбутньому адекватне відповідь вона хоче
крісло ти сьогодні не на порядку даних
фонду французький президент франсуа
олланд
висовувався на конкретний крок усі росія
продовжити авіаудари ми
адже європейський союз побачитимемо
сьогодні не буду нових санкцій, проте ми
всі разом за клацаємо до придушення
перемир'я поведеш загальному купити сумку
лідери не змогли зводять вдома термінал
стратегію ще до Росії у висновку
декларації через ікла режим асада та
Росію припиліть бомбарду Ваня-то за
безтурботний доступ до гуманітарної допомоги
до Алеппо